tom Fitton has been tracking the molar
investigation from the very first day
he's also the president of Judicial
Watch and he joins us now Tom is that an
unfair summary of what we've learned
have I missed something have we gotten
any indication of actual collusion a
year into this I know we haven't you've
been much to charitable tucker you know
it's honestly evaluate the Muller
investigation has been an unmitigated
disaster if the if the media were
covering the Muller investigation the
way it was covering the Trump presidency
I think we'd all agree it hasn't worked
it's failing it was created based on an
illegal leak by James Comey many of the
people who inspired the Muller
investigation were fired from the
government Sally Yates the acting
Attorney General Andrew McCabe the
deputy AG James Comey the FBI director
and Andrew became excuse me the deputy
FBI director all three fired from
misconduct they helped get the Bolar
investigation rolling you had the
Clinton DNC dossier that was hidden from
the American people being used evidently
by Mahler we have the Flint
investigation under attack because of
the corrupt way in which it was
initiated and investigated by the FBI
where they said he lied when evidently
he didn't and on top of that we've got a
federal judge questioning the ultimate
authority of mr. Muller and we still
don't know what his authority is a year
out because he's evidently had secret
conversations with the Justice
Department about what his authority is
and on top of it the Russia the Russia
investigation the key aspect of it the
Russia troll indictment it's now being
turned into an opportunity for the
Russia intelligence operations to go in
in a federal court and demand evidence
from mr. Muller about what they have on
Russia intelligence operations namely
intervention in our elections what a
disaster for the rule of law and frankly
the president has been victimized
through all of this because evidently
there's nothing to justify an
investigation of him requiring Justice
Department resources and authorities the
way that's been misused today but but I
I thought in quickly but I mean correct
me if I'm wrong the whole point of an
independent counsel is to assure the
rest of us that the investigation
on the level that is not tainted by
potential conflicts given that why
didn't Muller try harder to at least
seem bipartisan maybe hiring one
registered Republican as an investigator
he didn't bother to do that well it's
the arrogance the deep state they think
they can do no wrong and Muller and
comecome are part of the same team on
that regard on top of that you have him
hiring Democrats with abandon with and
then you have the page struck text
messages you know he kept those guys
that he kept those two FBI agents off of
his investigation because of bias and
hid that from the American people for
four months
you know mr. Comey if your typical
government official would have been
asked to resign a long time ago that's a
really good point tom Fitton
it's been following this from day one
thank you Tom you're welcome it's pretty
obvious that the Democratic Party's
relentless focus on Russia to the
exclusion of all else like issues that
matter to people may have been a mistake
politically an article this morning in
The Daily Beast makes a ludicrous claim
it says the Democrats actually wanted to
spend the last year-and-a-half talking
about real issues health care and the
economy but they couldn't somehow
because cable news stopped them Rachel
Maddow told them not to apparently cable
instead force him to talk about Russia
they didn't want to luckily we kept
copies of the tape and here's what they
actually said about Russia there is no
question that Russia attacked us for tax
ladies and gentlemen our Constitution
attack on the integrity of our elections
an attack on our democracy we are only
at the beginning of understanding what
the Russians did to affect our elections
I think there's a broad recognition
among our members that Russia is not our
friend why does it not worry Donald
Trump that the Russians according to the
intelligence community tried to and
indeed did kind of infiltrate and
undermine our democracy by what they did
Richard Goodstein is a lawyer he advised
both of Hillary Clinton's presidential
campaigns and he joins us tonight for
what's gonna be a tough conversation for
ya what I would say Richard because I
don't think it's not really plausible to
make the case look you can argue that
Russia hacked our elections as Democrats
have argued for the last year they're
our main enemy in the world as they've
also argued and you know maybe time will
prove you right I doubt it but maybe you
can't argue if you're a Democrat that
what you really wanted to talk about was
the issues you didn't really wanted to
talk about Russia you just happened to
talk about it non-stop for a year
nobody's gonna believe that because it's
a lie well again it's the intelligence
community tuckered not Democrats not
Republicans the intelligence community
is the group that said that the Russians
try to undermine our democracy so don't
lay that off for gee well there's no
intelligence community there are a
number of federal agencies some
exclusively devoted to Intel gathering
others partly like the Coast Guard
there's no intelligence community
there's no consensus under the director
of national television three pieces
every single person who's charged with
overseeing intelligence for this country
when asked and when their agency was
asked said that the Russians tried
interfere look the fact of the matter is
the Russians approached the Trump
campaign and said we have stolen
materials would you like them from the
Hillary Clinton campaign right Donald
Trump jr. said love it putting aside
what we have we I would say we've plowed
this ground before I what I'm asking was
a political question clearly this is not
bearing fruit for the Republican for the
Democratic Party there now they're
leaders within the margin of error this
is a political matter it's just not
working okay it's not they're not gonna
retake Congress on the strength of the
Russia story now they're telling us we
never wanted to talk about Russia in the
first place and all I'm saying is that's
a lie don't lie to me when I've been
watching TV for the past year and all
you've talked about is Russia see Rachel
Maddow make you do that I mean like
don't lie to me look the fact is I think
there's two tracks I think the fact is
the Democratic Party knows it's not
going to win this election they're not
gonna win the 2018 elections just
talking about Mahler or Trump even
they've got to have an affirmative Genda
about economic justice and social
justice okay but the fact of the matter
is Donald Trump we used to say he was at
historically low approval ratings I
checked today Jimmy Carter actually
edged him out so he's now second most
unpopular president this
intuitive restoration you're absolutely
back every single election every
election we just had that special
election in Arizona
Trump won by 21 the Republican won by
five every single Republican who won the
house last year by 16 points or under
has to be looking over their shoulder
and scared to death because of this
momentum isn't underrated
no okay there look Democrats have a lot
of energy it's a midterm in the
president's first term of course they're
gonna gain seats they're only been I
think two elections in American history
that didn't happen so it's gonna happen
but Democrats don't look like they are a
lock to win back the house given the
president's relatively little popularity
and you're absolutely right half the
country doesn't like him Democrats
should be way far ahead of where they
are today and the reason they're not
farther ahead is because they're not
running on anything and so they sent the
are they're running on things like more
abortion and more illegal aliens and
things that are insane and scare people
and you know that well again it will see
when when 2018 midterms roll around all
we know is from every other single
special election the Democratic wave
seems to be on the order of 10-15
percent and you can say what you want at
this point that will take out a lot of
incumbent Republicans will it continue
just for the sake of honesty will you
concede the Democrats didn't spend the
last year telling us that Russia hacked
our election Hector whatever that means
it was a lie but they didn't say that
because Rachel Maddow made them or
Morning Joe sent them a memo and they
had to obey they said it cuz they
thought it would work and it didn't they
were verified they were horrified that
the a the Republicans that the Russians
did this and B that the White House was
indifferent or worse was complicit
that's the thing that Democrats haven't
saw here they don't care about this
country if they care about the country
they'd secure the borders and fight back
against China I mean the countries that
are actually controlling our policies no
doubt for the Democrats at all because
they don't care we had a net outflow in
the last four or five years of the Obama
administration we had a net outflow
that's how much they care about the
border the people were leaving not
coming in yeah rich a good scene thank
you
sure good to see you